الينا الخبير الامني والعسكريه عمر الرداد
اهلا وسهلا بك سيده رداد يعني بوسيني يبرر
هذا القرار بنيه لندن ارسال ذخائر
باليورانيوم المنظم الى اوكرانيا بدايه ما
خطوره هذه الصفقه او هل بالفعل يمكن ان
يقدم الى يعني بعد نشر هذه الاسلحه هل
يمثل تهديدا بالنسبه للغرب
مساء الخير لك والاخوه المشاهدين اعتقد
فكره التهديد الى الغرب تعود بنا من
البدايه حول من يطرح استخدام
النووي ومن هذا المصطلح موجود في مفردات
خطابه اعتقد كلما تعرضت روسيا لضغوط
وتعثرت في تحقيق انجازات تطرح الملف
النووي والموضوع الاسلحه النوويه سواء على
مستوى الاسلحه الاستراتيجيه النوويه او
التكتيكيه بما فيها من اليورانيوم المنظم
لكن ما يلفت النظر ان الطرح الجديد اليوم
ياتي في اطار هناك فيروسيه وتحدي
ويمثل رساله تحذيريه اعتقد وليست تهديديه
للاتحاد الاوروبي ولناته تحديدا بانه اذا
ما تم يعني مشروط اذا ما تم وفقا للاعلان
الب بانه سيتم تجويد اوكرانيا بقذائف
بتحمي اليورانيوم بمعنى ان هذه الرساله
التحذيريه هي مشروطه
فيما اذا اقدم الغرب على تزويد اوكرانيا
بهذا السلاح رغم المبررات التي تشير الى
ان هذا السلاح يستخدم بالحروب وتحديدا من
قبل الولايات المتحده في مناطق مختلفه لكن
مع ذلك يبقى ما يؤكد على عدم جديه روسيا
وانها مجرد رساله تحذيريه انه السؤال
لماذا تنقل الى بيروسيا الدوله المجاوره
روسيا دوله يتواجد فيها منصات الاطلاق
والقواعد والامكانيات العسكريه
الجباره التي يمكن ان ترسل من خلالها
اسلحه نوويه سواء تكتيكيه او استراتيجيه
لاي مكان في العالم هذا يدل
على عدم جديه روسيا وانها مجرد تحديد وانه
مجرد تحذير ليس
الاصلاحات تكتيكيه ما المقصود بذلك
الاسلحه التكتيكيه
مرتبطه باليورانيوم المنظم والقنابل
القذره كل هذه تستخدم عناصر يورانيوم
وعناصر مشعه في هذه القنابل لكن الفرق
بينها وبين الاسلحه الاستراتيجيه النوويه
هو مستوى التفجير هو مستوى التفكير ومساحه
اذ انه يعني الاسلحه الاستراتيجيه النوويه
القنابل تستطيع ان تهلك وتبيد وتلغي مدن
كامله بسكان 30 وعشرين مليون بلحظه لكن
هذه القنابل تستخدم لمزيد من التاثير
بالعدو على مستوى الافراد وعلى مستوى
المعدات ونطاقات تاثيرها محدوده بمناطق
جغرافيه محدده بمعنى بساحه المعركه لكن
هذا لا ينفي وفقا لخبراء اليورانيوم
والاشعاع لا ين هذا تاثيراتها
التي تدوم لفترات طويله وينتج عنها امراض
سرطانيه هل هذا يعد يعني وفق القانون
الدولي هل هذا يعني
يوافق عليها يعني عندما تعلن لندن عن
ارسال باليورانيوم المنظمه الى اوكرانيا
ويعني علمنا بان هذه الذخائر لها تداعيات
على تلوث البيئه وعلى الص- يعني البشر
بالسرطان وغيره هل هذا يعد من الناحيه من
ناحيه القانون الدولي هل هذا يوافق عليه
اعتقد القانون الدولي
كما هو القانون الدولي يحرم استخدام
الاسلحه الكيماويه والاسلحه البيولوجيه
طيب لماذا يعني هذا هو ايضا تصعيد من قبل
بريطانيا في هذه الحرب
نعم نعم اعتقد بريطانيا لها موقف لا يخفى
على احد انه صحيح هي بالاطار الاقليمي
الاوروبي الى جانب فرنسا والمانيا كقوه
قائده لكنها تذهب بعيدا الى جانب الولايات
المتحده وربما يعني لا اريد ان ابالغ
بانها تلتقط المواقف الامريكيه وتعبر عنها
بطريقه اكبر مما تعبر عنها فرنسا او
المانيا وهي تحمل راس الحربه في قياده هذه
الحرب وبخطاب يتميز بالعنف والتشدد يقابل
الى حد كبير خطابات متشدده داخل روسيا
ربما تشبه الى حد كبير جدا الخطابات التي
يقودها اوقفها
شكرا جزيلا لك الخبير الامني والعسكريه
عمر ردد معنا من كنت معنا من عمان شكرا
جزيلا لك